Khloe Kardashian is screaming and
sobbing sucks in the juiciest keeping up
with the Kardashian teaser yet I'm not
just a TV show like this is my life
sometimes the world forgets just to be
kind that we're all going through
something Khloe Kardashian breaks down
as she sounds off on her ex Tristan
Thompson's cheating scandal it seems
like the show will also get into the
Jordan woods of it all
[Applause]
Khloe initially blamed Jordan for
breaking up her family after the model
admitted on red tabletalk she did make
out with Tristan I know I'm not the
reason that's Justin and Khloe are not
together I'm no homewrecker I would
never try to hurt someone's home
especially someone that I love and
someone who has a beautiful daughter
Chloe's since walked back with her blame
claim and a source tells et despite the
drama
Khloe is keeping her daughter a priority
quote true is the only thing that
matters not Tristan's lies she was the
best thing that's happened to me
it's difficult nothing is private
everyone feels like they have the right
to talk about you even though they have
absolutely no idea what's going on Kylie
Jenner speaks out for the first time
since Jordan became estranged from the
reality TV family in the sneak peak
something Kim K can't see happening in
the near future the West moving to the
Midwest for me to Chicago
Kim officially addresses Kanye's
comments about permanently relocating
their family back in September yay
claimed he was moving back to his
hometown and never leaving again we just
can't seem to catch a break
looks like tears talks and more tea to
spill when Keeping Up with the
Kardashians returns Sunday March 31st